ich habe fast den eindruck gab er war
richtig sauer ungeduldig mit den bürgern
der wähler hat geradezu geschimpft jetzt
haltet euch endlich mal dran und hat
eigentlich die alten regeln eigentlich
jeder kennt noch einmal aufgezählt für
mich waren das verzweifelte im kapelle
und das schimpfen der bürger das trifft
es genau richtig thomas und es wirkt
etwas
planlos und ratlos also man kann
natürlich weiterhin kritisieren und die
menschen auffordern und daran
appellieren und es ist ja auch richtig
wir wissen ja alle dass eine impfung
schwere verläufe verhindern kann
insbesondere todesfälle verhindern kann
aber wenn unseren politikern oder dem
fall auch dem chef des
robert-koch-instituts nichts anderes
einfällt als das was er seit monaten
eigentlich seit anderthalb jahren sagt
impft euch impft ohne einen wirklichen
plan zu haben dann macht mich das ein
bisschen ratlos und sprachlos also ich
hätte erwartet dass er wieder erklärt
wie er denn da dazu beitragen will oder
ersparen dass sich mehr menschen impfen
lassen warum reden wir noch nicht über
modelle der belohnung zum beispiel die
es in anderen europäischen ländern
gegeben hat oder auch weltweit gegeben
hat hingegen auch so ich wollte einmal
kurzen fragen das war auch gerade ganz
großes thema das die kontrolle auch
einfach fehlt es gibt auch viele unter
uns die sind vielleicht gar nicht gehen
aber trotzdem weiterhin in restaurants
auf veranstaltungen weil gar keiner nach
diesem impfnachweis fragt das wurde ganz
klar thematisiert hat jens spahn absolut
einen punkt hier ist dass auch
aufgefallen wenn ich in anderen ländern
unterwegs bin dass da viel häufiger
nachgefragt wird was ist mit dem
impfausweis oder dem test ausweis hier
in berlin zum beispiel wo wir es hin da
passiert das eigentlich nie hat man das
gefühl und das ist natürlich ein punkt
ja der rechtsstaat wenn der regeln
erlässt also wenn es 3g gibt dann muss
das auch kontrolliert werden und das
passiert nicht stichwort was zuvor
gerade sagt dass sozusagen aufgegeben
kein belohnungssystem neue ideen ich
fand das war ja eine
kapitulationserklärung als jens spahn
gesagt hat wer jetzt nicht geimpft ist
er will nach unseren informationen auch
nicht mehr geimpft werden das heißt er
hat die zahl nochmal genannt 16,2
millionen menschen ein drittel der
bevölkerung und man versucht nicht die
impfkampagne zu booster nummer in diesem
jahrgang zu bleiben sondern eigentlich
ist es eine kapitulation es war eine art
kapitulationserklärung völlig richtig
also wenn man die argumente noch einmal
wiederholt die bislang zu dem ergebnis
geführt haben was wir haben dann ist das
nicht das was ich von politikern in so
einer situation erwarte sondern dass sie
eine andere herangehensweise versuchen
und das war auch so ein bisschen aus
meiner sicht zu viel erklärung und pr
sprech darin dass sie entspannt immer
wieder gesagt hat ich habe dass er
bereits im august gesagt ich habe hier
gewann ich habe da schon von 2g
gesprochen also etwas was jetzt keine
rolle mehr spielt wir sind in dieser
situation was machen wir jetzt wer packt
an wer tut etwas und ganz wichtig das
thema altenheime auch da habe ich keine
konkrete idee gesehen er hat das problem
angesprochen hat gesagt ich will nicht
sehen dass es wieder so viele tote gibt
ja aber was machen wir denn dann also
wenn es nicht passiert diese impfungen
das ist zum beispiel nicht genügend
impfung in den altenheimen gibt dann
muss die politik etwas dagegen tun und
pressekonferenz halten sind das eine die
warnungen die mahnung okay aber wie wir
bereits festgestellt haben dass hat auch
in der vergangenheit nichts mehr